hello
hello how is it going everybody hope
you're having a good day
well for those of you who are not in the
u.s today is election day
so the nerves are a little touched and
people are just
anxious and just yeah
some real fun stuff and
i also have my neuroscience exam
tomorrow which i am
not ready for and peachy has been
very playful so i just wanted to
get the updates out there um but yeah
well
hopefully by end of the week we'll have
some
um more i want to say good news but i
feel like
there's yeah i'm just gonna say we're
gonna have some stable news
hopefully by end of the week or so about
the election
but i don't know enough about politics
to
speak very comfortably all i all i know
is well i'm a chess player i'm an
immigrant
so yeah so i just want to
show you some good chess let's enjoy
some chess let's look at some
really dynamic stuff and hopefully this
will
train our minds as well
um yeah so
you are most likely going to hear a lot
on the cat he has been extremely
just vocal so the thing is here in san
luis it had some really horrible weather
recently
but today it got really good so he
wanted to go out but i couldn't take him
out
because i had to study because of the
neuroscience exam tomorrow
and yeah so it hasn't really been
his day so to speak all right so
um i'm sure he'll forgive me with some
liquid tuna
but okay let's get to some chests
so um the first wait where is my breath
there's
there's my browser and i also have some
cheetos right before
yeah um so the first game i wanted to
show you
is a game that's van der and brunchtan
i'm probably i'm not pronouncing them as
if they should be but that's how i
learned them
and uh yeah this game was very familiar
i don't know if you guys can see this
part
but uh because this happened in the
candidate tournament so zurich
1953 so if you have not read that book
yet
you should like get it now get it today
that's one of the books that i always
recommend to people reading
i would definitely recommend reading it
with the commentary because there are
some versions that they just have the
games
so make sure you find the one with the
commentary i
do not know for sure where you can find
it
but i'm sure these books these books are
very popular it wasn't that hard for me
to find it when i was back in iran
years ago so this is a very famous um
game and a very famous tournament so
just be sure to
um put it on your to-do list all right
um
so this game the opening was pretty
normal they didn't really have
much novelties to it i just have a usual
i don't say usual kings indian yeah
thank you peter we should be able to
find it on
amazon and so i wanted to
ask who here has encountered
uh this position or at least place
kingzone in
with this setup
whoa you've never read anything on chess
huh
well to be fair write these days with
youtube and twitch and all the other
platforms people use a lot of the
classic games and teach it by what i'm
doing so
you don't necessarily have to have the
book but
i would always recommend having that um
that self-thinking and just deciding for
yourself and those stuff
so
all right great so um nobody really
plays this wow i am a little shocked
i thought there would be at least i want
to say five or six people
okay so okay i see some nice comments
are coming in
all right great okay so yeah i mean this
isn't
there's not something super specific
about this
um like i feel like and like anybody
can should be able to play any opening
but in
the lower levels people generally have
um
um like a preference so i consider
myself lower level compared to the super
grandmasters obviously
so for me like i have a like
i prefer to play really active so if you
give me a very dry position
um that's very strategic very dry that
it doesn't
i can't really come up with much uh most
likely they're not either i'm gonna mess
it up or
even if i don't mess it up i'm just not
going to be able to win it all i can do
is hold it
so that's why um in lower levels it's a
very good idea to actually know what you
want to play
and just look around with games just see
what what
type of opening what type of chess feels
right to you
and yeah i think that's something that
would help you your specific
uh chats a lot all right so i'm glad i
mentioned that okay so um
oh i see some uh
ah steve north i remember you from
twitch channel
if i'm not mistaken um
all right cool what
what exactly do i recommend why
well i'm not exactly recommending
the well actually i thought the analysis
were by
naidor for the zurich 1953 tournament
um but
well i recommend it because it was one
of the great tournaments that
i feel like it's one of those classics
the same way i feel like you should know
the history of your country
it's a good idea to know the history of
chess and
a lot of the great players just played
in it
so i think you should have an at least a
basic foundation on it
and but that's not the only reason it i
think that was
there goes the cat with his explanation
i think that was one of the
first tournaments that it's kind of like
had that foundation of analysis to it
but um yeah uh it's
it's really hard for me to explain i
just i really liked
reading it hello grandmaster fishy
uh all right so
yeah i think so too peter i've i've
heard different things about it as well
okay so um i i actually
put i don't play this king's indian too
often i played it
occasionally when i was still hunting
down dorms
um but yeah so this might see five ideas
actually pretty interesting you're
trying to just going after this poor
pond
i've actually never played this a5
myself there has been other lines that
were tried but a5 makes sense because
well
at some point this b4 is coming and when
you think about it a little bit
different from a different perspective
uh this is kind of the moroccan pawn
structure well with the mark c like
there is usually the pawn of c5
that has been exchanged and then like
the c pawn
is usually like on e7 or and
so that's a little bit that little
slight difference
um but like
you still have those ideas this bishop
is still holding this giant diagonal
this bishop should still
figure out where it exactly wants to go
um
so there's still similarities so it
doesn't hurt you
from understanding the moroxy type of
structures
okay um oh i think he's still north
that's very nice to see
um what's who's the highest rated oh
that's a hard question i
i mean well this wasn't rated well it
was rated but it wasn't a classic
game it was a rapid rate game i played
fabiano
i helped i held it for good um
i got it opening correctly i think i
didn't feel too miserable
after the opening and then time travel
in the middle game i just collapsed
but yeah i think i don't think i've
played anyone higher than him
well okay um
[Music]
let's just think a little bit about this
position so
one of the things to know is this idea
of a group b1
so as i mentioned in the maroxy type of
structures
white generally wants to gain as much as
a space
that's that's not a secret and this
bishop over here
is looking towards the stroke which kind
of and the pawn on a5 is kind of like
paralyzing white's
queen side so in order for whites to be
able to
somehow break through white needs to
deal with this
issue right so i think one of the ways
is to consider exchanging these bishops
but at least right now that's either
[Music]
i wouldn't really recommend that because
even in the real marroquin type of pawn
structures you don't really want to do
that
you know i usually take this knight if
taken and
you go back for those of you who are a
little bit more theoretical
um so you don't exactly want to change
it the other reason is because this
bishop would just
look really weird if your other bishop
is not on the board anymore
your bishop is just um looking towards
these two
central ponds that are the same color
and
um they don't really want to have bad
bishops right
so group b1 is
kind of another idea that white could
have gone with
and the idea is just simple you want to
get this b b pawn moving even though you
will give up the a
file you are still kind of like getting
that space and just trolling around
some um some
uh i was gonna say some ponds but i
don't think that's exactly right you
shouldn't throw our own pawns
anyways that's something that's uh it's
worth considering
just depending on how much you want this
space
ah i see the green screen now huh
i usually don't watch myself on youtube
i just read the chat so i'm
just i'm looking at it on here and i see
huh this green screen is actually
not very pleasant sorry about that uh
no actually my cat doesn't i don't think
he wants to play chess he wants to go
outside and hunt stuff
he actually killed a bird not by
actually catching it by scaring it to
death
so that was a very um weird thing that i
have seen i tried to like give the bird
a little like mini cpr with just like
finger on the heart and all and yeah
that that poor guy was gone
i never thought my cat could scare
anything like that
so when yeah
yeah i don't know the the cat is uh just
yeah he he does interrupt a lot
and he's also very cute and it kind of
balances out
but yeah during exams especially and
during the tournaments
yeah anyways um
enough about the cat stories so queen c2
so
my question for you is black to move
what do you think black should do
you you know the ideas from both white
and black side
well we both want space we're both gonna
fight for space
we are both trying our best to well
because the center is still pretty
mobile mobile
uh you can still do a lot
to um fight for it and poke around in it
so that's something to keep in mind oh
thank you
yeah those are very great our ideas
thank you aaron
and um
let's see
why did it stop hold on
ah there should be six interesting
i agree the nikon d4 is unprotected
but you can't you don't really have like
a tricky way to attack it
because if you take it well um you take
this can't i just simply
sorry take back and i don't
think that's going to be very pleasant
the f6 square is going to be
kind of painful um
yeah your brook is also undefended i
don't really like this guys
yeah this uh yeah no no there
are way better ways to go about it
so i don't think we should move this
knight right now
i either would like to develop so i
either wanna like um
do something with this bishop or i kind
of want to continue
fighting for um space
so those are kind of my two choices
hello kitty
what do you want to see
let's see what else
i'm not sure about that
um maybe hold on but i still don't see
the right move honestly
let's give it another try guys um
i so yes c6 is a pretty cool move
but what is your idea
i think c6 is a great idea another
move that i was thinking that you guys
could potentially
offer was a4 i thought these two moves
would be
um bishop d7 i feel like bishop d7 is
just too chill bishop comes to e3 or
comes with d1
i don't really know what like what do
you want to do with this bishop
yeah um so i'm not super familiar with
these type of positions either i kind of
play this as white so i have a general
idea of what white wants to do
um but not necessarily what black should
do
honestly but one thing that i learned
playing oh he wants headrooms
uh playing like different openings is
just
no please don't sleep on the mouse uh
it's just the ideas with c6 and b5
those kind of really shine in a lot of
the games
let me let me remove this a
furry horrible
yeah he's getting a big boy
okay um
interesting but i i still might taste
and
then you'll take it back with the palm
and
yeah your pawn structure gets weird but
good good idea with the tricky uh
pin i think that was interesting all
right so c6 is actually the best move
um the thing with c6 is that now if you
continue with bishop e3
now i'm gonna bring the knights back so
the idea of the c6 is not
just to um well attack for d5 or b5 it's
more controlling these
squares and you kind of are considering
them well not right now obviously
but you kind of just want to give
yourself that option
to have it like up your sleeve and you
can just whip it out whenever you want
um but i really like this idea with my
d7 97 is a very great idea
you are opening your bishop you might
want to relocate the knight and go poke
around there
so i think this is a very cool idea um
so white plays rook d1 simple moves
uh i was thinking maybe e3 would be a
little more prophylactic
but d1 and a4 because well the knight is
on c5 depending
um the pawn you're just gaining space
and you guys are going to see how
important it is to
continue pushing this pawn so
that's something to keep in mind yeah i
see the cat is gaining a lot of
popularity among you guys yeah it's
great actually
um
maybe we could do that that's i mean a
possibility depending on what the
position requires
but i feel like my e5 is more realistic
just going around for that but again
we're going
see it really depends on what the
opponent does for example
best move right now anybody wants to
take a shot at it and tell me what's
about what would be the best move for
white
i agree c6 does look a little um
just weird like not the first one you
could think about
so ah what is f4
um so the thing about f4 is
f4 is actually doable but when you play
f4 you're very committed
to just playing in the king side and
center and you're kind of giving up on
your clean side
so either thank you thank you um i see a
the right move in the chat b4 is the
right move
so uh either you are going to fight for
um both king and coincide which is what
you ideally want to do
with a move like b4 and after b4 will
take
take queen a5 you know taking over space
and now black has to figure out how to
get this guy out
um the best suggestion was to
stop b4
and get the other knight down and then
you're gonna slowly try and figure out
what to do with this bishop you know
it's not that easy for black to be able
to do that
and um apparently
if i'm not mistaken this game was played
um in olympia 1982
so the correct move of b4 was played
about
30-ish years almost 30 years after
this kid the game between uh roshewski
and brunch name so however rachelski did
not play this b4 in the game and he
simply played knight e2
so now you saw how
white can um get
well how white should have gone about it
and how white should have fought for the
queen side
but now with knight e2 what do you think
black can do
how do you think black can use this this
um
this mistake huh why am i wearing a
tiara i got that question reported this
is
not a tiara this is just a headband
a plastic one as well it's like
yeah so i don't know why you guys want
to see me in the tiara
but yeah
i'm good i'm good thank you your slob
yeah it's been going
kind of weird i procrastinated on
doing the studying for an exam that i
have tomorrow
so i am pretty roasted
toasted all of the just yeah
i have to watch about five hours of
lecture and
read the study guide that if i'm not
mistaken
is about 45 pages
um all right
i don't really see the right move
honestly in the chat just yet
and oh this is actually kind of cute
tracy is asking if chichat is behaving
yeah
chad is behaving i probably shouldn't be
reading this out loud but tracey's
saying good stuff right yeah the chat is
usually behaving
sometimes towards the end some somebody
shows up from somewhere and
it gets funny but
let's see no
nothing so oh
thank you arianne i think you were the
first one who set the current field with
queen 85
so queen a5 is very interesting because
i i get it when a5 looks weird because
you're technically dropping
your d6 pawn but the thing is with queen
a5
remember in the other line even when
white played the best moves
we still did this queen a5 that is
another idea with c6 to free the queen
right we wanted to free this queen and
for those of you who play this line with
white or have more experience in this
pawn structure
in maroxy or uh
the sorry marxy pawn structure you kind
of know that
this idea with queen a5 is pretty famous
the only thing is that in sicilian
there is no pawn on c7 anymore so
this pawn is already moved
yes mr pishi and um
so white goes there we go up there
now what do you guys think about rook
takes d6
do you think that's a good idea for
white or
should why shouldn't do that
oh so while you guys are thinking about
the best before
black i'm gonna ramble and complain
about this
stray cat so this uh there's a stray cat
that comes behind the door
every single night pretty much
as soon as the sun was going down and
well of course i feed him creatures
leftovers and my leftovers and all
but the problem is that i put the food
like a few meters away
so he eats it he chills he goes but
um unfortunately
this guy really wants to play with my
cat
so he always comes behind the door and
just gets fishy all um
riled up and all and it's not as fun as
it sounds
it's cute for like few minutes and then
and i actually had a baby fight
yesterday i opened the door to see if
the other cat wants to come and fishy
sprinted out
and they kind of hissed at each other
for a little bit
it was interesting fishing rarely hisses
so that is my crazy cat story
now let's see um
ah well thank you for watching all the
way from germany
this game i mean i'm sure this game was
very famous so either you've seen it
before you're gonna see it later
or you could simply just well watch the
rest of it later
so thank you for watching
good to know there are a lot of cat fans
here so yeah this is
some romance going on actually i don't
know if that cat is a female of male but
my cat is a male
okay so the thing is i i
i see that there are some confusions
about uh
this rook d6 well rft6 is definitely
worth considering
but the problem is knight e5 and now the
c4 is pretty
um what's the right word i was gonna say
poked
i think that's that's yeah that's what
i'm going to choose the c4 pawn is
pretty poked
and white can only play something like
c3
sorry b3 to defend it and then we're
going to take and then we're going to
simply do a little mini baby tactic
of taking over there and the knight
of three and the the rook on e1 falls
and
when that falls the queen on a5 just the
king on e1
is just basically just gonna be like
christmas
so yeah this is not so very pleasant for
white obviously
all right oh from indonesia nice
all right so that is why actually with
d6 does not work because well white has
way too many holes in his
position for rookie d6 to actually work
so white has to be very careful and that
is another reason
why this idea that b4 or b3 was a good
idea to just try
and somewhat covers a lot of those holes
all right so white find bishop of one
knight e5
logically right you'll see this little
one poke over there
and so now white does sorry black to
move
what do you think uh branch name should
do
oh i see some
ha um well
exquisite uh cats are not romantic i
don't think they're
they're having like a romantic thing
going on it's more like
just playful but yeah
i don't really want to have another cat
as long as um
if she's around maybe my peaches old
i'll get a baby cat for fishy to train
how to be a cat
i have a problem with fostering but i
just
i can't imagine actually liking another
cat as much as i like peachy
so that i think yeah i feel like it
won't be fair to the other cat
yeah but
also peachy might just you know squat
tell the other cat so that's always
something to consider
ah so there is still a vote for bishop
e6 all right
so i still haven't seen ah well um
cm the pawn on is already on a4
do you mean a3 and keep in mind that
because we have so much more space in
the queen side
it's not not necessarily a bad idea to
just
gain more space
yes i kind of like this a3 idea and well
so did brunch thing
uh spoiler alert
yeah a3 was a pretty cool idea um this
is kind of
this is something that i've seen a lot
of games happen
like you don't necessarily you you might
not necessarily be able to calculate why
this is a good idea but just getting
that space
department like a3 or like h3 just like
those are kind of a
um it's just one of those things that
the more you play
chess you kind of get a feeling for it i
think
is good um oh for example if any of you
watched the games that i did the us
championship
or any videos that i did about the games
that i played in the us championship
um you guys would know that's the game
the first game that i had against sabina
that was pretty much it i i couldn't
calculate why
i mean what i mean how the g5 would
pan out why where when how all of those
fun stuff
but i just knew that in that game that
i'm talking about the first round of use
championship
i knew that g-pod was the only chance to
gain some space
get some creativity and stuff like that
so i feel like it's the same with a3 you
can't exactly calculate every single
move
um you have to just calculate that okay
you're not wondering
so i think that's the bare minimum that
you should do
what about knight e6 i think knight e6
um sorry knight e6 could be interesting
but i kind of like my knight here
i don't really feel any i mean 96
okay 96 if you don't play a3 then 96
should be the movie you do
i like it yeah um because
uh white's kind of stuck if you try to
play
another something like king g2 to stop
the knight f3
then i could just take it and play
bishop e6 i i could live with this yeah
i think this is pretty cool
this is pretty doable uh but a3
the thing with a3 is that
it's kind of just
it's really destabilizes
ah i said the word uh the queen side so
when you go ahead and play something
like b3
now there's even knight f3 you take that
and then c3 is falling and this one is
already too far
and uh just just imagine we get this
position now
actually knight takes b3 is a serious
threat
so i don't think this is something it's
just
one of those moves that you're also kind
of like throwing the ball in your
opponent's chord because if you play
knight e6 king g2 is the only move
so white will most likely find it it's
the only move it's not that hard
but when you play a3 now it has to
decide do i want b3 or do i want to do
something in the king side
so i kind of like that that idea about
just
forcing the opponent to make the
decision between
a little bit and like a little worse
than that
[Music]
all right so we have a very meowing cat
yeah the the stray cat is behind the
window
so peachy is very anxious because i did
not have time to take him outside today
oh boy all right so
um why plays this f4 now
quite quick question this wouldn't be
too hard but what do you think we should
do
as black oh boy no blue
cat is not hungry he has been fat
cuddled brushed
loved treats i gave him treats drank
slapped everything he just wants to go
out and play
yeah the cat agrees with active going
out and stuff
yeah if he continues meowing i'm gonna
have to force love him and bring him
over and just
hold him right here
yeah so what do you think black should
do do you see any um
any like uh kinky stuff or you just want
to bring this knife back
i don't want to see any tactics honestly
i mean you could consider
no just taking here is also not very
[Music]
take take what would i do next okay i
gotta take this with the bishop
then what am i doing we're making g3
yeah i mean it's possible but
now i want a meal it's not necessary i
could just simply bring the knife back
the thing is white is like unnecessarily
making his position
more susceptible to poking
and just getting more unstable
so next you could just try to you know
do a cool maneuver there
the other thing is um
the other thing to consider is that
black is actually playing way more in
the queen side
and a little bit in center so it's a
good idea to bring
more pieces to that side right compared
to
if you wanted to keep your pieces in the
king side and form something like that
because well let's face it when you're
going to poke white in the queen side
locks what's going to poke you back in
the king's side well
you do queen side he's going to do king
side so you might as well just prepare
it and don't give too much opportunities
to your opponent
um unless you are one of those people
who loves calculating
then in that case yeah you can do some
crazy stuff and just calculate your
calculator until your brain hurts i
avoid
too much calculation because i'm
generally a tired sleep-deprived person
as a student
pre-med studying for mcat so
so i don't want to spend too much time
calculating
um so if you have too much time on your
hand and you want to calculate
go ahead and go for it but if you feel a
little
more practical or slash lazy or
whatever you want to call it that yeah i
wouldn't say i wouldn't
give up this night it could it could
turn into a beautiful sacrifice it's
going to
it could turn into a disaster so to me
knight d7 is definitely the new
all right um
so knight comes back e3 and just knight
a6 you see
some poking material there we go this
other knight is coming up there too
all right let's go up there i don't
guess you're p3
hello kitty um
why what's the purpose of e3
i thought something like g4 should be
the way to you like you push g4
and you're gonna try and just form some
sort of attack otherwise you will
white is kind of just busted
um so
yeah rook e3 now whoa
well
kitty i need you to sit down
oh it is hard to be a cat parent not
an actual parent i can't imagine so
to all the parents out there you
everybody you guys deserve like a
real treat like a night off ice cream
wine whatever
this is yeah parenting is hard
little upper little cat i mean just her
little cat little one for a real
baby human okay
um so rook e3
black to move what do you think you
should do the first thing i really want
to do is knight b4 ah thank you yeah
so knight b4 let's just go for it the
knight belongs on b4 it's not like i'm
actually going to bring this line to c7
again so
let's just go up now black to move this
is actually a kind of an interesting
position just because
it's not too complicated but you have to
actually know
how to um how to
manage it so you've got to show some
skills so black to move
what do you want to do oh boy
oh no no please don't drop stuff come on
kitty
now he's in the rebellious stage he's
dropping stuff
from the table
oh um exquisite yeah no thank you
no um yeah
if slash when i have a kid i want my mom
here my mom is raising that kid i want
to go to work man
um yeah the kid
can give me a call when he's 18. not
kidding i i like children
but now raising children is just
yeah and yeah it needs to help it takes
a village
i'm glad that in us the concepts of
working mom and just like
daycare and all is such a um acceptable
thing because in iran it's not
like they would criticize you if you go
to work and leave your kid behind at
home as a woman
they would criticize you if you don't so
there's not really like the nannies are
not a real thing i think it's
kind of interesting how in us you can't
really lift the kids
alone before a certain age i think the
age is
like 13. please correct me i don't know
exactly
but yeah i think that's that's also very
interesting that you actually have to
have it
um another like the teenager watch over
the kids
i think that's a yeah i think that's
actually i really like
that's one of the things i really do
like about us
okay so back to chess let's stop talking
about
babies and babysitting and yeah i ain't
gonna have a baby for a
foreseeable future um
so blah blah counterpoint well okay so
i i get your idea that i saw a lot of
gorgeous ideas with f5 thank you for
sharing i do think that f5 is definitely
interesting
my problem with f5 is that it's not
tricky enough
if you play f5 white has a lot of
options including something like g4
including something like simply bishop
to g2
and i don't exactly like that about it
so that is why i would not play f5 in my
real game i kind of
i cannot kind of i want to play bishop
d7
normal simple moves and i want to see
you i want to see
you as white make the good groups if you
make the good moves if you can
hold your position and show off all of
your skills not sure you deserve
the points uh whatever you going to get
well
i mean like half a pointer the whole
point but um
more often than not opponents tend to
not necessarily
[Music]
necessarily just find all those right
rules
unless it's like a very easy position
like
so um yeah we can definitely
look at um bishop d4
line oh there should be four line i
actually did not think about this
and knight p3 huh i guess your idea was
with a2
well i'm definitely gonna take that
queen makes a2
this looks very interesting but my
problem is rick takes d6 at the end
and i don't really know what to do about
that
am i missing something because
i feel like if the d6 pawn wasn't
staying it would still be playable
for one for black but i don't really
like this honestly i don't wanna
enter a worse end game i have so much
more activity here
compared to that end game
all right i'm glad this clarified things
up
oh the cat's gonna drop stuff all right
um where were we
what about your b8 ah
i'm not really sure about your v8s
at least not yet oh my god you guys can
see this but i'm like
holding a fight with peachy over here
over my flash drive
all right from from next time you kitty
are going to be locked in a cute little
only one i have to teach all right
ah cats um
[Music]
sorry for the cat's little commercials
okay um
i was talking about f5 and then i was
mentioning bishop d7
and you had a question about bishop d4 i
hope those are solved
all right again if you want to buy f5 f5
is perfectly fine
you can't do it just my problem with it
it's too simple and it's kind of forced
his opponent's hand into going for g4
next well dorset takes care no he's way
too cute to be taken
i could force hug him
um so i i kind of
like bishop d7 because bishop d7 is a
simple move
i might want to do b5 i might just want
to wait and see what you do do you want
to do e5 do you want to do f5 do you
want to do g4
honestly as white i think i would go for
either bishop c2 or g4
because i don't think that this this
center is ready to be pushed
just yet but even even a very strong
player such as roshevsky
made the mistake of playing e5 so you
can understand why
i've learned my lesson on not rushing
into things
so rushing into f5 f5 feels like a very
big commitment like
you meet someone on a monday and you do
a
vegas wedding by thursday f5 feels like
that
i don't know why i use that expression
um but
at the same time like bishop d7 is just
a little bit more chill just slow you're
gonna let the opponent make the mistakes
you're gonna show them all of those fun
stuff
i have not graduated from college it is
my last ish year
but there's a lot of there are a lot of
classes i want to take and it yeah
we'll see okay so
everything goes yeah exactly thank you
so that sounds actually
pretty correct everything other than
bishop d7 does seem like an over push
uh yeah so
now white plays e5 so at black we don't
really have much electrodes we're gonna
take that
right and you can see that white's
attack is already kind of
not as promising anymore
compared to something with g4 and
potentially something like that i want
to bring the bishop out there
so e5 take take um i think the
main thing that you should worry about
right now
is your bishop on d7 not the fact that
this rook is
in front of us so just thinking
logically about it
most of your pieces are in a very
reasonable position
honestly i wish my bishop was a little
this bishop was a little bit more
activated
but right now well we can't really do
much about it we could just bring rook
d8
and i do like that idea rook the eighth
you're simply
uh defending it and the rook is not
really doing it that much on a8 anymore
so that's kind of why we bring it back
well
we don't have to bring it back we never
moved it we finally developed it
uh you could consider other options such
as queen c7
nothing wrong with that computer
actually suggests
h5 which i didn't really think about
before i saw that
so i don't think that's it exo i think
that
it was more like he couldn't it's not
that he couldn't calculate
um it was more like black has a better
stable position so white has to use
something dynamic
to um get it done
otherwise white is not gonna have a very
pleasant
game so i think that was a mistake that
he rushed it and a lot of player rush
moves
you can see today's top-level hill i
don't think there was anything
top point today but these days top chess
and
see how people rush into moves anyways
am i from russia now that is actually
funny i
have my gran my great grandma
had some mixed blood and stuff but no
um okay so
if i take take with d8 and y plus g4
now in the spirit of rearranging pieces
what is the next piece you want to
rearrange
well axel it's not that the attack stops
white still
does have some potential with these
squares right
if the knights could get over here or
over there this bishop
could get activated that could still be
pretty um pretty promising for white
um dominic my
name would go uh somewhat like dorset or
actually and yeah i
am i am from iran uh abdullah
well garlic thank you for the wish but
can you modify it a little instead of gm
wish me like an md if you're praying for
me i want the md first
you know working towards that is really
hard right now
well not as hard as i should be but
still
all right oh thank you yeah i agree 96
gorgeous yeah 96 you're blocking the
pawns you're attacking this night
and a lot of the chess is about
understanding when to back off
so right now you gotta back off this
night's job
is somewhat um kind of done
so you gotta back off this knight's done
over here
bishop which four and we're finally
gonna take over there well
keep in mind that bishop bishop takes d8
knight takes
e2 and that's a check
um takes d4
and so now black to move how can we
play tricky this game is continuing for
a while
so i'm gonna probably rush into some of
the moves but this one i really would
like it if you guys could
um tell me what you think black
should do shouldn't be that part of a
move since black does not have that much
luxury to you know move around too much
what is md md is uh the title that
doctors get or do do is also another
title that doctors in the us get
md is a little bit towards why more
towards what i want because i want to um
become a surgeon so
do you all the surgery gets a little
even more competitive
do i hold the chats regularly huh i hope
so
all right yeah good to know oh the cat
is still
holding the show well i guess
i gotta talk to the club for a
deployment for pc as well yeah tracy
can you get right on it please pc
i'll be his manager i'll take 10 percent
uh all right so
um
yeah all right yeah you gotta play
queens
that's it that's the trickiest you can
be at least in this position
especially because well i mean
you don't really have much of an option
your roof is under attack you move the
stroke your bishop drops so
you mean you gotta just go for queen c5
um rookie four and now another tricky
move
bishop h6 you're simply poking around
and making the most of your position
so i um this was actually a hard route
for me to find
but i'm gonna give you guys about 30
seconds to see
to get some ideas so
feel free to let me know what you think
you should do but keep in mind i'm only
giving 30 seconds
whoa we should be five more for six
no well hold on actually there's blacks
bishop
f6
ah thank you watching from poland i i
played in poland uh
once and i had so many polish friends so
glad to know no this is oh wow aryan
you're strong
yeah this one was hard for me to find
when i looked at it first
so it took me a good couple of minutes
before i
gracefully gave up um yeah this one v6
is actually the best move to go
the thing is if you were to take the
rook
i'll take back and rick d2 is coming
so that's why this move is so strong
not because of well sacrificing is
because you're opening up
your um you're opening up
your um pieces to
a lot of activity and dynamic chests and
that's kind of the thing here we're
looking at a lot of dynamic chests and
the games
um rashford played g5 and honestly from
now on
black position is just very great well
the knight is supposed to be here but
the knight is there
being pretty useless you open the room
for night
we have bishop of five ah we got rid of
that useless bishop that we had
and now again regrouping you could come
over to e-citings you could just move
the queen and go to c5 so you're just
simply
um real
regrouping and reorganizing your presets
which is actually pretty great
so in the game why play e6 because
honestly if this knife got to e6 this is
a very
uh unpleasant position for white
white is played pretty paralyzed what is
wrong with
pawn f4 then
after capturing you take a bishop um
dominic
i don't know which position you're
referring to because they're
con f4 i haven't been able to
make f4 movement last
few minutes so if you actually if you
could tell me
in which position i would definitely go
back and take a look at it
ah z is saying knight before well
the knight wasn't before we just came
back and we're kind of facing with e6
right now we're trying to regroup the
pieces
you got to take that i know i think
one of the last questions that i will
ask you for tonight is are you going to
take this
or are you going to play rook f8
ah is that a bishop e6
well in this position rook f8 is
actually best i'm going to take a second
to just
see what about this
well i guess you're tall you're
mentioning f5
dominic i don't try um
yeah i mean f5 could be but the problem
is if i was just the pawn takes
if you take over there there's f7
the i don't like giving too much
activity but
yes if you can't find the bishop e6
doing something like f5 or bishop e3 in
this position
is the best choice but all right let's
just get to the position
that we were at brooke f8 yeah
so rook f8 is actually the best move and
the thing with dr kf8
is that this bishop is a monster you're
coming up with bishop d4
you're gonna bring the knight hello
and so white tries to drop
e7 but even then we have this bishop d4
rook's gotta move and now again just
queen of five
attack simple moves now you can actually
see
so according to engine this move is
actually like right now the position is
still pretty zero
zero but you can feel how much it is
better to be black black is the one with
pretty much all of the threads
and with the better pieces so
yeah i think that's another thing to
keep in mind
when it comes to dynamic chess and
activity
all right so queen of five in the game
rushovsky went rogue e8
and um following what we've been doing
with bishop d4
queen of five are lovely one move
threats we're gonna continue
that one more threats are awesome
honestly as long as you're improving
your position and getting your dynamic
chest on why not one move transfer
perfect
all right so again in this position
this is another thing to really just
try and get the cat out of the camera
is um how much this position is
so um weak for white
like the pawn on g5 is falling uh
this pawn on a3 is completely dominating
the queen side
so so you can simply take it over there
if queen is here queen g3 and now
my most favorite move of all time maiden
ones
it's the easiest to calculate right so
in the game
white tried to throw in some chests and
defend the mates
and well you can easily see how
uh this just comparing those two bishops
together makes me laugh a little
haha uh but the fact that black is also
pawn up in the king side and the spawn
is on a3 on the queen side
yeah those are some real fun stuff
um i don't really get in g2 it's just
simple check
and ah this is such a lovely end game
okay so um ah
i should have timed my class a little
bit better
i really wanted to get deeper into
anything i don't know why
a simple 65 move game takes so much time
but
yeah i kind of like to read the chat and
answer all right
i'll try to uh power true before
daryl has to start is end game but okay
so um we can all agree that
exactly black is better thank you yeah i
think
that's what i was just gonna say we can
only agree that black is better it's
just a matter of
how you're gonna win this well first of
all don't blunder
second of all i will blend the cat nope
no question there
third of all uh you have to keep your
activity so
you mean obviously you shouldn't
exchange your squeeze right away
um but you could simply
poke around with the queen a little get
the king back there
bring your own so imagine if your king
is already somewhere there when you
exchange the queen right yeah you can
simply eat that
so that's kind of the idea yeah exactly
so um
let's go for that get space
kick the king get more space and
finally bring the king this is what
we've been waiting for
again you could potentially start trying
to exchange queens and get the king to
beat you
but um ideally you will
ideally um we kind of want to keep the
activity we want to see if we could get
anything
out of the game when the queens are
still here so
i don't get this idea but
i like the threat of making one this one
if king goes to g2 queen h2 mate
anyways um all right so
the idea is simple the black is kind of
prolonging the inevitable that you
as black want to exchange these queens
while
you get the king up there and white made
this
weird mistake before i i don't get it
and this is just actually wrong
so yeah um
the design thing is actually very
interesting so
there's there's not just a one way to
win it there are a lot of different ways
to win it one of it was this
to just kind of um zooms along your
opponent
uh one of it the easiest way that i
could think of was simply getting the
king to a5
on the right time and um exchanging the
queens and getting the king to beat you
and eating the pond uh well i'll do
i like to see where why misplay the two
but i think white kind of started to get
weird
all the way back when the whites chose
to play
e5 around here
white rushed into it and prematurely
played this e5 instead of g4
and black has shown very great technique
into winning this game
so yeah i'm sorry that's we had to rush
into
some of the last moves but feel free to
just check that out game on your own
this is a very
lovely end game or well if darwin has
time you could talk him about it and
ask him to show you more about it um
and well if not i will see you guys
on friday on twitch for some end game
i will talk more about this endgame the
first position that we will do on twitch
on friday from five to seven
so be sure to show up and
we will have some fun with the cat and
yeah all right well this is actually
very great
thank you everybody from all around the
world that you stayed and you watched me
i'm going to go study for my tomorrow
exam and
also kind of want to watch how the
election is going but all right so
uh have a great rest of your day slash
night
and i will see you all on friday